very rare that a man will come up and
attack you they're going to be polite
maybe a bit creepy whatever but they're
not going to ever attack you it's these
feminist women who see what you write
online and they will come up to her and
there she is and they'll do trickery
deception Street tactics you know like
real Street tactics deceptive stuff oh I
love you hey girl all this crap bang
cracker in the face there was a
crackhead looking woman who came up just
the other day I was about to grab later
to move around the way but then I
realized after two seconds it was cool
unlike the creep this morning but these
are the people you need to be careful of
it's the feminist women it's the
transgender women the blue haired women
they're the ones who feel oh it's girl
on girl come on we're allowed to fight
men it's very rare where they would ever
dare get physically confrontational with
you